Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Papst ist tot. Wann wird der weiße Rauch aufsteigen?
Sobald Donald Trump den Nachfolger bestimmt hat.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 521 vom 25.
April 2025 Ja und noch gibt es kein Habemus PAPAM Wird noch gerätselt,
Wird das auch in Wettbüros mit Sicherheit oder?
Das ist bestimmt auch so ein Thema in den Wettbüros wenn der nächste PAPS wird Wie wäre es mit J.D.
Vance selbst jetzt wo er den PAPS umgebracht hat wäre doch eigentlich genau der Richtige.
Also so, ich meine, als moralische Instanz ist J.D. Vance auf jeden Fall,
ja.
Das wäre doch mal was. Das ist geil, oder? Ich meine, den Typen sollte man jetzt
einfach mal überall hinschicken irgendwie.
Also der hat ja so eine Audienz beim Papst. Tag vorher, dann war der Papst tot.
Das hat er nicht mehr verkraftet. Dann könnte man ihn jetzt mal so auf Tour
schicken. die ganzen anderen alternden Vögel auch noch abzuräumen.
Ja, also ich kann mit der Institution Kirche wenig anfangen.
Wirklich? Jetzt wird es ja an jeder Ecke zugeschissen, mit was der Papst alles,
was das für ein guter Mensch war.
Hat, glaube ich, die eine oder andere gute Sache gemacht.
Ich glaube, dem hat man ein Ferrari geschenkt bekommen, dann hat er den signiert
gesegnet, verkauft, hat Geld den Armen gespendet.
Das hätte Donald Trump nicht gemacht.
Insofern,
also gemessen an den Anzeigen,
an den moralischen Instanzen, die gerade die Welt beherrschen,
schien der am besseren Ende zu sein.
Ja, ausgerechnet das Oberhaupt einer Pedrastensekte ist da irgendwie überzeugender.
Ja, naja. Auf jeden Fall die Argentinier sind jetzt nicht mehr...
Nein, das war schon ein ganz cooler Typ.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Ob man die Leiche da irgendwo hinlegen muss und da jetzt hinfahren muss.
Nee, muss man erst nicht.
Aber er hat auch zum Beispiel, also er ist ein sehr bescheidener Mensch.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn du auf so einem Anwesen lebst,
hast du natürlich auch kaum noch Bedürfnisse. Aber sein Testament ist kurz.
Irgendwie ein schmuckloses Grab in seiner Lieblingskirche irgendwo in Rom.
Hast du gelesen, ja?
Du, Tim, du kannst es ja nicht wegmachen. Das ist ja überall.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie. Aber ich freue mich, wenn auch mal was anderes
in die Nachrichten kommt, als immer nur Trump hat gesagt, Dummheit.
Also, naja. Atmen wir tief durch. Dann wird jetzt nochmal ein neuer Papst gewählt.
Gucken wir mal, was das für Auswirkungen hat für die Welt.
An mir ist nur vorbeigeflattert, also auch habe ich ja nicht weiter gelesen,
Donald Trump will zu der Beerdigung kommen, Friedrich Merz nicht ich hätte jetzt
grundsätzlich gedacht, dass Friedrich Merz dem Christentum näher steht als Donald Trump.
Friedrich Merz fährt er deshalb nicht hin, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt noch der Scholz
Kanzler ist der ist ja noch nicht Kanzler Und der Scholz, der wird da hinfahren.
Aber der Merz ist ja quasi noch nicht Kanzler.
Und das finde ich auch angemessen, dass er das nicht tut.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass wir jetzt seine Christenhaftigkeit daran festmachen sollten.
Aber er wird dann sicherlich zum nächsten Papst fahren.
Und dem den Ringfinger küssen.
Genau.
Hoffentlich überlebt er das.
Das wird das wieder so ein Schnellläufer wie dieser Johannes Paul der Erste
oder so. Wie lange war der irgendwie im Amt? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich verfolge das nicht.
Was, echt nicht? Du bist nicht irgendwie bei Papenjungs?
Ich habe, glaube ich, mehr Ahnung von der dritten Fußball-Bundesliga als von...
Ja, aha. Wer ist denn da der Erste?
Ratzinger.
Ich weiß es nicht, komm.
Papst Johannes Paul I. war 33 Tage im Amt und dann ist er von J.D.
Vance besucht worden und das war es dann mit ihm. Genau.
Papst ja, ne Moment, ist das der zweite Papst, den J.D. Vance auf dem Gewissen hat?
Das ist nur so ein Witz. Aber dafür war er ja bekannt.
Also er ist halt Papst geworden und ist nach 33 Tagen gestorben.
Das war halt die kürzeste Papstkarriere. Das war,
1978. Daraufhin hat sich ja dieser Karl Wojtyla, dieser polnische Papst,
der halt deutlich länger war und so weiter.
Ja, hat sich ja deshalb sozusagen Paul der Zweite genannt. Und ja, so war es.
Der wollte also eigentlich auch nicht lange machen. Aber der hat sich dann lange
quälen müssen. Das kann ich noch sehen.
Der war ja jahrelang, haben die den armen alten Mann dahingestellt und da hat
der da versucht, noch irgendwie einen Text zu äußern.
Das ist schon Ja.
So ist halt nun mal. Der Einzige, der sich da rausgezogen hat,
war dieser Ratzinger. Der so Ah ne, Papst, voll anstrengend und so.
Ich mach jetzt nicht mehr.
Macht ihr das mal? In gewisser Hinsicht kann man sagen, selten,
dass in der Position jemand mal einsieht, wann er sich zurückziehen soll.
Da kann Trump noch einiges lernen vom Ratzinger.
Ja.
Naja, gut.
Wobei ich meine, ich fände es jetzt auch nicht schlimm, wenn der von Papst Franziskus lernt.
Hauptsache, der lernt irgendwie von den unterschiedlichen Wegen ein Amt auch
wieder zu... Was, den Vögeln zu predigen oder was? Bitte?
Den Vögeln zu predigen? Achso, das war ja nicht, achso, der Franziskus war ja
der aktuelle. Ja, nee, davon wird er wahrscheinlich weniger lernen.
Ja, aber ich, also Hauptsache auf
irgendeine Weise das Amt aus den Händen lassen und seien es die Kalten.
Wer war denn dieser Papst, der den Vögeln predigte? Ja, das war auch Franziskus,
das war der erste Franziskus.
Franz von Assisi, genau.
Aber Tim, weißt du eigentlich, mein Name, Linus, der war ja früher selten und
dann lernt man viele Dinge über seinen Namen.
Unter anderem, Linus war der Nachfolger von Petrus und ist damit quasi der zweite
Papst, weil Petrus war ja der erste Papst.
Linus ist der zweite Papst. Ich bin da quasi in einer direkten Nachfolge.
Linie, in einer direkten Nachfolge.
Aha.
Okay. Das war mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ganz klar.
Ich wusste auch noch nicht, dass Linus Altgriechisch ist und Lied oder Volkslied heißt.
Es gibt tatsächlich sehr viele unterschiedliche Bedeutungen,
die dem Namen Linus nachgesagt werden.
Eine davon ist der Klagende oder der Beklagte.
Okay. Aber auch der Sohn des Apollo.
Ja, ich stehe da in sehr ruhmreichen Linien.
Erst 1990 wurde der Name populär und etablierte sich nach der Jahrtausendwende
unter den 50 beliebtesten jungen Namen.
Das ist ein Problem übrigens auch. Also ich meine, wenn da irgendwo Kinder sind,
das nervt dann schon, wenn da alle 10 Minuten die Linie ist.
Ich kenne das auch. Tim hieß auch kein Mensch, als ich geboren wurde.
Und auch danach erstmal eine ganze Weile nicht. Also es hat glaube ich ewig
gedauert in meinem Leben,
bis ich überhaupt mal einem Tim begegnet bin und dann nahm das auf einmal irgendwie
krass zu und dann ist der Name auch unter den Top-Namen glaube ich in den letzten 10,
20 Jahren war irgendwie teilweise sogar Platz 1. Ich kann das ja auch verstehen.
Aber weißt du, wir hießen Tim und Linus bevor es cool war.
Das können wir so mal festhalten.
So, jetzt kommt Feedback.
Also, wir haben am Rande darüber gesprochen, das Thema kann man sehr viel vertiefter
behandeln, dass Trump sich ja jetzt mit den Unis anlegt.
Dazu kommentiert Johannes.
In Harvard sollte eine Liste mit Leuten herausgegeben werden,
die an den pro-palästinensischen Protesten teilgenommen hatten.
Zusätzlich sollte unter anderem eine Art politische Aufsicht installiert werden.
Das wurde von der Unileitung verweigert. Als Antwort darauf droht Trump,
Harvard jetzt die Erlaubnis zu entziehen, als Grund auf dem US-Visum angegeben zu werden.
Das wäre dann auch rückwirkend. Also quasi die Erlaubnis, dass ein Harvard-Besuch
zu einem Visum, eine Begründung für ein Visum ist.
Genau weiß man noch nicht in allen Fällen, was das für wen bedeutet.
Die Studentenvisa sind nämlich federal, bei uns also etwa Bundessache.
Die Arbeitsvisa der Lektoren und Mitarbeiter kommen von den Bundesstaaten.
Aber welches Recht in den USA noch für wen gilt, wenn es darauf ankommt, ist vielen dort unklar.
Mein Bruder ist dort gerade Postdoc. Wir halten uns bereit, ihn kurzfristig
aufzunehmen, wenn er nach Deutschland abgeschoben wird.
Solche Zustände hätte ich vor ein paar Monaten noch für unmöglich gehalten und
ich neige eher zum Pessimismus in solchen Dingen.
Ja, wird mal ein Deutscher abgeschoben. Warum nicht mal ein Deutscher?
Könnte man ja auch mal machen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall absurde Zustände dort.
Also es gibt, ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das jetzt schon Exodus nennen kann,
aber es gibt wohl schon eine ganze Menge, die sich jetzt mal so informieren
darüber, wie man denn so in Deutschland vielleicht mal arbeiten kann.
Wissenschaftlich sicherlich wird es hier eine größere Abwanderungswelle geben,
wie intensiv die ist und wie lange die anhält.
Das muss man mal sehen. Aber womit sich natürlich die USA gerade komplett ins
Knie schießt, ist dieser Mythos des freien Landes etc.
Also das wird selbst, wenn kurzfristig
da wieder irgendwas zurückgedreht wird, was ja zu erwarten ist.
Ja, das ist trotzdem der Schaden ist angerichtet.
Genau, der Schaden ist angerichtet und ich habe mich halt die ganze Zeit gefragt,
ob wir zum Beispiel jetzt in Deutschland überhaupt die Möglichkeiten hätten,
so eine Bewegung dem auch entsprechend zu begegnen.
Und ich glaube, das könnte schwierig werden.
Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Top-Professoren abwandern wollen,
hast du natürlich das Problem, erstmal gibt es für die überhaupt keine Kohle hier.
Also so wie die Unis hier ausgestattet sind und welche Möglichkeiten die haben,
da ist dann halt sozusagen überhaupt kein Vergleich.
Die kommen ja her und sagen, kannst du nicht arbeiten. Und wenn sie das dann
doch irgendwie ermöglichen, dann stehen natürlich alle deutschen Professoren
und Anwärter hier nochmal doppelt auf dem Schlauch.
Die können ja noch nicht mal ihre Mitarbeiter festanstellen.
Also das könnte dann auch für eine Menge Ärger sorgen. Das wäre jetzt eigentlich
genau der richtige Startschuss für eine neue Regierung, falls man sowas immer hätte.
Hier eine komplette Bildungswende zu vollziehen und zu sagen,
wir fördern jetzt mal hier richtig den Bildungssektor und zwar sowohl den bestehenden
als auch den potenziell von außen Anwachsenden und wir erlauben jetzt auch mal
mehr Zuzug von solchen Studenten, aber wir haben ja genau die gleiche Scheißdebatte mit Migration hier,
die das auch alles erfolgreich verhindern wird.
Ich glaube, da wird am Ende dann eher noch UK und kann er davon profitieren.
Also ich sag mal, die nehmen uns die Studienplätze weg, wäre jetzt noch so genau
das eine Tröpfelchen, was die deutsche Migrationsdebatte noch vermisst.
Dann hatten wir über die CVE-Datenbank gesprochen.
Und da hat F30, schönen Gruß an dieser Stelle, noch einiges zu ergänzen.
Hallo ihr beiden, zur Frage nach der Anzahl der CVS, ich hatte ja einfach auf
die Zahl geschaut und gesagt, die ist inkrementierend, also wird es ja im Zweifelsfall
so viele Schwachstellen geben.
Aus der höchsten vergebenen Nummer kann man nicht direkt auf die Anzahl schließen.
Die Nummern werden nicht alle direkt von Mitre vergeben, sondern indirekt über
CVE Numbering Authorities, CNAs.
Eine CNA reserviert einen bestimmten Bereich und kann möglicherweise auch noch
Teilbereiche an Sub-CNAs weiterreichen.
Die Nummerierung ist also nicht unbedingt fortlaufend, es gibt Lücken.
Hinzu kommen noch Entwicklungen, wie das der Linux-Kernel angefangen hat,
für sehr viele Bugs CVIs zu vergeben, ungeachtet der praktischen Security-Relevanz.
Kurzum, die reine Zahl sagt wenig.
Dann kommentiert er noch weiter, wir hatten über AI-Coding gesprochen und zu
den AI-Coding-Vectors.
Ich sehe weniger die Gefahr, dass diese direkt in Produktivcode landen.
Das wird schon auch mal passieren, aber da gibt es, wie von euch besprochen,
hoffentlich ein paar Checks und Quality Gates.
Was ich hingegen häufiger beobachte, ist Vibe-Coding, das von dir angesprochene
Konzept, dass man einfach programmisch schafft durch einen Dialog mit einer AI.
Zum Ausprobieren, Rumspielen für Demos oder Proofs of Concept.
In diesen Fällen läuft der Code zwar nie produktiv, wird aber durchaus mit Userrechten
auf den Laptops der Entwicklerinnen ausgeführt, mitsamt aller Libraries, Backdoors etc.
Das reicht auch, um zum Beispiel Secrets abzugreifen.
Ich würde gerade in solchen Fällen zu angemessener Isolation raten,
zum Beispiel mit Dev-Containern.
Wird oft natürlich nicht gemacht, weil es ja gerade darum geht,
schnell und ohne großen Overhead loszulegen. Ähm.
Also guter Punkt, ja, bei beiden würde ich zustimmen, dass das jetzt irgendwie
massenhaft in Prod ausgerollt wird, ist sicherlich weniger wahrscheinlich,
als mal eben so eine spontane Endpunktinfektion.
Das sollte man bei der Entwicklung von malicious libraries auf jeden Fall berücksichtigen.
Man kann jetzt noch hinzufügen, in der Zwischenzeit hat sich ja auch die CVE
Foundation gegründet, also als Reaktion auf die Streichung dieser Mittel.
Das ging dann relativ schnell. Es wird wohl gemunkelt oder ich habe das auch
so gelesen, dass sie wohl schon vorbereitet waren.
Also man rechnet mittlerweile schon mit dem Entzug und sie hatten sich da quasi schon aufgestellt.
Ja, genau, dieser Vertrag wurde verlängert. Der hat auch echt ein krasses Volumen.
Es ist schwierig, den USA irgendwie, also ich meine, das ist ein Jahresvolumen
von 56 Millionen. Das ist jetzt natürlich ein absoluter Rundungsfehler für das US-Government.
Gleichermaßen ist diese CVE-Datenbank etwas, wovon die komplette Welt profitiert
und ich fände den grundsätzlichen Gedanken zu sagen,
wir stellen das jetzt mal von einer 100-prozentigen US-Förderung um auf,
keine Ahnung, wirft jeder ein bisschen was in den Topf, ist jetzt kein so schlechter Gedanke.
Ja, und ich würde vermuten, dass sich das dann im nächsten Jahr so auch entwickeln wird.
Ob das jetzt die CVE Foundation ist, wir hatten ja auf andere,
da sind ja alle hingesprungen und haben gesagt, nein, nein, nein,
diese Datenbank brauchen wir, die muss auch bleiben und das ist ja auch richtig so die notwendig.
Da profitieren ja auch alle von und offensichtlich springen da ja auch sehr viele auf und sagen, oh,
da hätten wir schon noch Geld, damit das weiter bleibt und insofern ist es erstmal
vielleicht keine so schlechte Entwicklung, das auf ein internationales,
resilienteres Funding umzustellen.
So, du wolltest über Elon Musk sprechen.
Eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich möchte ich nicht über Elon Musk sprechen,
aber man muss natürlich schon mal auch hier berichten, was da eigentlich so gerade so abläuft.
Das ist einfach ja auch aus Security-Aspekten durchaus interessant.
Also es gibt einfach immer mehr Berichte, wie diese Doge-Truppe so vor sich
geht und man muss sich das einfach mal klar machen.
Also der hat da unter diesem Deckmantel Government Efficiency im Wesentlichen
so eine Hackertruppe engagiert.
Das sind alles so 19- bis 21-jährige junge Helden, die also teilweise auch schon
einen ziemlich unangenehmen Hintergrund haben.
Also die aufgefallen sind, in anderen Firmen da gefeuert wurden,
weil sie nicht trustworthy sind und so weiter.
Das scheint so ein bisschen so ein Pool zu sein von solchen Musk-Jüngern,
die sich da zusammengetragen hat, die also alle auch noch sehr formbar sind,
aber eben irgendwie was drauf haben.
Wir können das, glaube ich, ganz gut nachvollziehen. Das ist ja so,
wenn du so ein Computer-Whiskey bist und,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht seit 14 schon irgendwie alles auseinander schraubst
und so einen natürlichen Zugang hast zu den Maschinen, dann...
Kann man sich sehr schnell auf alles einstellen, aber wenn man dann so einen
Patronen hat wie Musk, der einen
dann auch noch mit absurd viel Geld und Machtversprechen bewerfen kann,
dann gehörst du schnell mal zu so einem formbaren Team.
Dem irgendwie alles egal ist.
Die machen dann halt einfach alles und so scheint er dort auch vorzugehen.
Es gibt jetzt einen Whistleblower, Daniel Berulis, der konkret über einen Vorfall
bei dem National Labor Relations Board berichtet.
Das ist so eine unabhängige US-Behörde in diesem gesamten Government-Konstrukt,
die natürlich auch von Doge dann, ja man kann sagen wirklich attackiert wurde,
denn es läuft dann immer so nach dem selben Prinzip.
Da tauchen dann auf einmal schwarze SUVs auf mit irgendwie Security-Begleitung
und dann reitet da irgendwie diese Hacker-Truppe ein unter diesem Vorwand mit durch.
Ja, wir brauchen jetzt hier mal irgendwie Zugriff.
Im Vorfeld haben die sich dann schon über alles mögliche informieren lassen,
was es denn da so für Systeme gibt, was denn da für Clouds benutzt werden und
auch was es so für Security-Mechanismen gibt.
Dann sind sie da irgendwie eingeritten und haben dann darum gebeten,
dass alle Monitoring-Tools abgeschaltet werden,
Logging-Mechanismen ausgeschaltet werden und im Wesentlichen waren die dann dabei,
dort eine Backdoor zu installieren oder zumindest Daten auch aktiv abzusaugen.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt gerade, also das ist natürlich für alle diese Behörden,
auf die sie da losgehen, ein Problem.
In diesem Fall von National Labor Relations Board. Das ist halt so eine Behörde,
die sich darum kümmert zu überwachen, dass halt irgendwie Unternehmen ihren
Mitarbeitern auch die Möglichkeit geben, sich in Gewerkschaften zu engagieren.
Also, dass sie da Mitglied werden können in der Gewerkschaft und dass sie ordentliche
Tarifverhandlungen führen können und so weiter.
Das ist ja jetzt eh nicht so die Stärke der USA.
Aber wir wissen ja auch aus Schweden, wie geil Elon Musk Gewerkschaften findet.
Ja, Spoiler, überhaupt nicht geil. Da gab es ja diesen dauerhaften Streik,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob der immer noch anhält, wo einfach die Schweden gesagt
haben, wir machen jetzt hier nichts mehr, wir reparieren ja auch keine Teslas mehr.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt hier nicht diesen Gewerkschaftstreit, also in Schweden ist
es noch selbstverständlicher in der Gewerkschaft zu sein, als es jetzt in Deutschland der Fall ist.
Ja und so gehen die dann da vor. Dieser Whistleblower hat dann so einiges vorgelegt
und ich tendiere dazu, das als wahr anzusehen.
Es gab dann auch noch den Bericht, dass dort kurz nachdem die dort aktiv geworden
sind, es auch Zugriffe von außen gab mit IP-Adressen, die aus Russland kamen und so weiter.
Das lässt sich natürlich jetzt nicht so richtig zuordnen. Aber Tatsache ist,
dass hier es super fishy abläuft.
Der Whistleblower selber hat dann auch noch davon berichtet,
wie er dann selbst unter Druck gesetzt wurde, so Nachrichten an seiner Tür mit
Fotos von ihm mit seinem Hund im Spaziergang, oben von der Drohne berichtet und so,
fotografiert und das ist schon alles ziemlich scary shit, was da gerade abläuft.
Auch wenn Musk sich ja jetzt ein bisschen zurückhält, weil er wohl gemerkt hat,
dass die Nummer für sein Business irgendwie nicht so gut ankommt.
Ja, da gibt es zwei Aspekte.
Einerseits ist seine Position des Special Government Angestellten,
die hat eine zeitliche Limitation.
Also er kann diesen Job nur für eine bestimmte Zeit machen, dann muss der in
irgendeiner Weise formalisiert werden.
Zweitens, ja, die Tesla-Aktie hat sich, glaube ich, seitdem halbiert,
Umsatzeinbruch bei Tesla, ich glaube, irgendwas 70 Prozent hatte ich zuletzt
gelesen, kommt ja immer darauf an, auf welchen Zeitraum man da schaut.
Und ja, kommt halt offenbar, tut es dem Geschäft nicht so gut.
Also hat er jetzt gesagt, passt auf, ich kümmere mich jetzt wieder um Tesla
und bis Ende des Jahres gibt es dann jetzt eine autonome Fahrzeugflotte irgendwo
in Texas. Das kennen wir ja inzwischen, das Versprechen.
Ja. Gleichzeitig wird er sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht, also nur weil er sich
potenziell hauptsächlich wieder inhaltlich anderen Dingen widmen möchte,
heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass diese Tätigkeiten aufhören.
Gleichzeitig habe ich ein Interview mit ausgehender Frau von der Heritage Foundation
gelesen. Das sind ja nun auch nicht unbedingt die Sympathen.
Sind das nicht sogar die, die dieses 2025-Ding geschrieben haben?
Ja.
Genau, die sind nicht unbedingt so angetan von den Musk-Aktivitäten und sagen, naja,
pass auf, ist schon richtig, die rennen da mal durch und streichen an schmerzhaften
Stellen einfach mal so zweistellige Millionenbeträge.
Aber das wirkliche Problem der USA liegt ja ganz woanders.
Dass jetzt irgendwie, wenn die Steuereinnahmen senken und die Staatsausgaben
erhöhen, ist eigentlich nicht das Interesse, was diese Heritage Foundation tatsächlich hätte.
Also auch für die, die das, was sie da machen oder symbolisieren,
ideologisch offenbar angemessen fänden, die sind auch nicht unbedingt zufrieden.
Wäre schön, also jede Beschäftigung für Elon Musk,
In anderer Form ist erstmal wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Schade. Oder ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob dieses Doge dann damit auch eingestellt wird.
Also das halte ich, würde ich nicht denken, dass das passiert.
Nein, nein, darum geht es jetzt glaube ich nicht und nur weil er sich auch in
der Öffentlichkeit nicht äußert, glaube ich auch nicht, dass diese Aktivitäten
dann schon beendet sind.
Das ist bloß halt, wir sind jetzt in so einer Phase des Total Infighting,
also jetzt fangen die einfach an sich alle gegenseitig an zu schreien,
also Musk hat es sich wohl mit diesen ganzen Ministern ordentlich vertan und
es sieht halt jetzt mittlerweile auch, dass diese merkwürdige Zollpolitik,
die Trump dort vom Stapel gelassen hat, ihm ja auch schadet.
Ja, das ist ja sozusagen, also zwar stellen sie ihre Model S und X irgendwie
komplett in den USA her, aber so Model Y und so weiter, das kommt ja alles aus China.
Und mit den Zöllen ist natürlich für sie ein Riesenproblem.
Mal davon abgesehen, dass der ganze Zuliefermarkt, gut vom Zuliefermarkt ist
jetzt Tesla konkret selber nicht so ganz so abhängig, aber grundsätzlich ist
es auch nicht gut für ihn und es ist ja überhaupt generell nicht gut,
ich meine es ist alles nicht gut, was sie da gerade machen.
Sie riskieren einfach gerade sowohl das Wohlergehen der Weltwirtschaft als eben
auch spezifisch diese Vormachtstellung der USA in finanzieller Hinsicht.
Also im Prinzip ist ja der Dollar als Reservewährung insgesamt in Gefahr und
das ist ja quasi die Basis der amerikanischen Dominanz.
Also sollten sie das jetzt einbüßen, dann ist schon mal klar,
wie Trump in die Geschichte eingeht.
Also da liegt ja auch für uns in gewisser Hinsicht eine Chance.
Also es ist, diese Selbstdemontage der USA wird mit Sicherheit dazu führen,
dass bestimmte wirtschaftliche Machtverhältnisse etwas nivelliert werden.
Nur wie anstrengend der Weg dahin werden wird, das ist sozusagen noch offen,
aber dass die USA dabei auf der Verliererseite sind, das ist glaube ich jetzt schon ziemlich klar.
Ich mir gerade nochmal kurz, also nur die Daten, die sich diese Doge-Leute einverleibt
haben, Labor and Immigration,
dann Immigrant Surveillance, Social Security, also die gesamten Social Security Daten,
Dann, was du gerade schon erwähnt hattest, National Labor Relations Board und
dann irgendwie so Public Health, da sind sie auch schon irgendwie reinfrisiert.
Also es ist ein absoluter Irrsinn.
Total.
Gut.
Gut. Ja, absolut.
So ist es halt. Dann schauen wir mal, was in Europa so abgeht.
Diese Nachricht bettet sich jetzt so ein bisschen auch noch in ein größeres Feld ein.
Und zwar, es gibt gerade von uns weitestgehend unbehandelt, mal schauen,
ob wir da nochmal einen schönen Podcast mit Daniel machen,
diese ganze Zollgeschichte, wo die
USA wirklich weitestgehend
ihrem eigenen Nachteil und ohne erkennbaren
Anlass durch Verhängen von Strafzöllen gegen die ganze Welt inklusive einer
weitestgehend von Pinguinen friedlich bevölkerten Insel den Weltmarkt einfach
mal geblutgrätscht haben.
Du kennst dieses Memen von dem Radfahrer, der friedlich fährt,
einen Stock in sein Vorderrad rammt und dann quengelt.
Also das ist ungefähr die Situation des Weltmarktes gerade und der Fahrradfahrer
ist Donald Trump oder die USA.
In dieses Umfeld tritt die Europäische Kommission nun mit der ersten Verhängung
von Strafen auf Basis des DMA.
Wir erinnern uns der DMA, der Digital
Markets Act, ein Regelwerk der Europäischen Union, das zum Ziel hat,
digitale Märkte,
die sich als Märkte in privater Hand zu einem so großen Ausmaß Bedeutsamkeit verschafft haben,
dass sie nun als quasi privatisierter Markt und damit auch Markteintrittsbarriere
bei der Ausübung einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung dienlich sein können.
Bestes Beispiel hierfür von uns häufig diskutiert ist dann eben der Apple App Store.
Gleichermaßen aber auch Meta und hier geht der Digital Markets Act rein und
macht Vorgaben für diese Märkte, die,
im Bereich des Verbraucherschutzes liegen, aber auch im Bereich der Marktregulierung und fairer Wettbewerb.
Jetzt gibt es eine Strafe für Apple von 500 Millionen und eine Strafe für Meta von 200 Millionen.
Das sind natürlich für diese Unternehmen eher formale Strafen.
Ja, das ist also jetzt nicht so, dass bei Apple irgendjemand sitzt und sagt,
oh fuck, wo holen wir jetzt die 500 Millionen her?
Aber es ist natürlich ein Signal. So, was wird Apple vorgeworfen?
Apple wird vorgeworfen mit dem, oder was heißt vorgeworfen?
Es wird konstatiert, dass Apple mit dem App Store einen Marktplatz geschaffen
hat, zu dem es keine Konkurrenz gibt.
Und zu dem Apple als Bereitstellende des Betriebssystems auch die Konkurrenz aktiv verhindern.
Wir haben das hier sehr viel besprochen, dass das einige sehr positive Konsequenzen.
Für das Ökosystem iPhone hat, aber eben auch einige negative,
weil es bestimmte Einschränkungen gibt, die einfach von Apple diktiert werden,
die dann für die Nutzer und Nutzerinnen einfach gelten, man nichts dagegen tun kann.
Und dann hat die Europäische Union gesagt, das ist nicht, das muss jetzt anders,
ihr müsst alternative App-Stores zulassen.
Es muss Konkurrenz geben zum App-Store.
Und dann hat Apple gesagt, ja, okay, machen wir.
Und das haben die quasi auch in Reaktion auf den DMA gemacht.
Und jetzt ist es, sagen sie, sagt die Europäische Union oder die Europäische
Kommission, die diese Strafen verhängt, Naja.
Verhindert trotzdem einen Wettbewerb, weil der eigene App-Store gegenüber den
anderen Betriebskanälen bevorzugt wird.
Es ist also nicht so, dass irgendjemand kommt und sagt, hier pass mal auf,
iPhone, pass mal auf, du willst Apps wahrscheinlich hier kaufen,
sag doch mal in welchem App-Store, hier ist eine Auswahl.
Das machen sie zum Beispiel bei dem Browser.
Also das Browser-Default war auch etwas, was die beklagt haben und ich stellte
dann fest nach irgendeinem iOS-Update, dass mein iPhone sagte, na,
hast du Lust auf surfen?
Such dir doch mal einen Browser aus. Du könntest Safari nehmen,
du könntest aber auch, was weiß ich, Chrome und was da für unterschiedliche
Browser, Brave und was nicht, alles angeboten werden.
Dann sagst du mal, was dein Default ist und dann suchst du eine aus,
dann machen wir das. Und dann kannst du dich nachher wieder ändern.
Bei der Browser-Geschichte, das ist offenbar zufriedenstellend gelöst worden,
bei der App-Store-Geschichte noch nicht.
Es gibt weitere Verfahren, die noch nicht entschieden sind.
Also die Browser-Geschichte ist offenbar jetzt zufriedenstellend gelöst.
Weitere Verfahren ist, dass es eine Apple Core Technology Fee für Entwickler
gibt, auch wenn die ihre App außerhalb des App Stores veröffentlichen.
Ich glaube, das heißt, oder wahrscheinlich aus der Sicht der EU ist das quasi
eine Gebühr, die nicht zulässig ist,
diese Core Technology Fee, weil sie wiederum auch für Leute zutrifft,
die sich komplett aus diesem Apple-Markt verabschieden wollen.
Und sie sagen, es ist unnötig schwierig und verwirrend für EndnutzerInnen,
Apps aus alternativen Stores zu installieren.
Das sind die Dinge, die sie denen vorwerfen.
Jetzt gibt es also mal 500 Millionen Strafe. Mal gucken, wie sich das weiterentwickelt.
Dazu muss man natürlich sagen, das sind jetzt erstmal vorläufige Entscheidungen.
Also das ist jetzt noch nicht final sondern das ist jetzt sozusagen eine veröffentlichung
und Pressemitteilung der EU-Kommission, wo sie sagen das ist unsere Sichtweise
und wir drohen euch jetzt diese Zahlung an,
und jetzt wollen wir aber nochmal mit euch reden und ihr könnt euch jetzt dazu
äußern, das ist sozusagen kein,
finales Urteil da fließt jetzt noch kein Geld.
Ja, wenn man sich diese Dokumente anschaut, dann ist so ein bisschen unklar,
was sie aber jetzt eigentlich wollen.
Also gerade bei dieser Core Technology Fee, also das sollte man vielleicht nochmal
kurz erklären, wir hatten das ja hier auch schon seinerzeit,
als das rauskam, mal erklärt.
Aber derzeit läuft es jetzt so nach den Veröffentlichungen in dem iOS App Store
man kann halt eine andere App Store App installieren,
das war am Anfang nur übers Web möglich, da gab es jetzt nochmal eine Änderung
jetzt muss ich zugeben, dass ich gerade die letzten Änderungen dahingehend nicht
mehr so ganz im Kopf habe, ich habe es auch irgendwie auch mal gemacht, ausprobiert,
auf jeden Fall ist es möglich und man kann geteilter Meinung darüber sein,
wie leicht es dort einem gemacht wird.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie jetzt groß im App-Store angepriesen werden.
Mit hier sind andere App-Stores.
Surprise, surprise. Das ist aber auch nicht gefordert worden.
Und das ist überhaupt so ein bisschen auch das Problem, was ich jetzt mit dieser
ganzen Situation habe, mit der Position der EU, dass sie eigentlich nie so genau
sagen, was sie eigentlich wirklich wollen.
Weil in dem DMA steht jetzt irgendwie nicht, dass Apple sowas nicht hätte tun dürfen.
Also da stand nicht mit, zu welchen Kosten solche anderen App-Stores erlaubt werden sollen.
Dazu meiner, also ich habe nichts gefunden zu diesem Thema.
Da steht nicht, es muss kostenlos sein, sondern nur, es muss möglich sein.
Ich finde es aber schon inhaltlich jetzt erstmal nachvollziehbar, zu sagen,
ja, muss möglich sein und selbstverständlich muss das möglich sein,
und du darfst dieser Möglichkeit nicht noch Steine in den Weg legen,
die nicht als unmittelbar notwendig verargumentierbar sind.
Weil natürlich sofort bei einem Stein, der da noch in den Weg gelegt wird,
ein Grund zur Annahme besteht, dass der da liegt, um diese Konkurrenzsituation
zu behindern und zu erschweren.
Klar, natürlich.
Und insofern kann ich schon nachvollziehen, dass sie sagen, wir werden jetzt
keine abschließende Liste der Bedingungen machen, aber wenn wir sehen,
dass da irgendwo ein Stein liegt,
dann werden wir mal genau gucken, wie schwer der ist und ob der inhaltlich begründbar
ist und im Zweifelsfall ist das nicht und deswegen werden wir dann sagen,
dieser Stein muss weg oder wir wollen 500 Mio.
Ja, aber da wird es halt wirklich schwierig, weil die EU ist ein Legal Buddy.
Da geht es darum, dass sie irgendwie klare Gesetze und Regelungen und Richtlinien
und Verordnungen oder wie auch immer man das nennt, machen und sagen,
hör mal, das ist das, was ihr tun müsst.
Und wenn ihr das nicht erfüllt, dann können wir dagegen vorgehen.
Jetzt beklagen sie in diesem Text diese Core Technology Fee,
die halt, das habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht ausgeführt, im Wesentlichen so eine
Paper Installation Kosten ist.
Das heißt, wenn du den App-Store auf den Telefonen vorhältst und auch die Apps,
die dann über diesen App-Store, diesen alternativen App-Store installiert worden
sind, wenn die dann sozusagen verbreitet sind ab einer bestimmten Größenordnung,
dann musst du pro Installation dafür bezahlen.
Und in diesem Dokument steht jetzt nicht, dass so etwas generell nicht verboten
ist oder dass sie nur den Preis dafür für zu hoch ansehen.
Und das steht halt weder im Gesetz, noch steht das jetzt hier in dieser Verlautbarung.
Da muss ich mich halt auch fragen, okay, was ist es denn jetzt?
Also was genau wollt ihr denn jetzt? Also mit anderen Worten,
sie verhängen jetzt Strafen für die Missachtung eines Gesetzes,
in dem das, was sie beklagen, nicht drinsteht.
Also es ist sozusagen nicht geregelt. und das ist halt, naja,
aber das ist die Realität, weil wenn du jetzt als Unternehmen da drauf schaust und sagst, ja okay,
wir sollen das ermöglichen, ja hier guck mal, haben wir jetzt ermöglicht,
ja kostet zwar Geld, aber wir haben es jetzt ermöglicht und so weiter.
Also das ist so ein bisschen problematisch und ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich nicht so richtig,
wie es dazu überhaupt kommen kann, weil das einfach dem Prinzip der klaren Regelung
vollständig widerspricht.
Wir haben, also um dir ein Beispiel zu nennen, das historisch bekannte Beispiel,
dass Microsoft eine sehr große Strafe dafür zahlen musste, dass sie ihrem,
Betriebssystem Windows 95 wird es wahrscheinlich gewesen sein,
ein Softwarepaket vorinstalliert mitgeliefert haben mit dem Namen Internet Explorer.
Welches,
Und sich dadurch zweifelsohne, also ganz klar,
das ganze Unheil, das der Internet Explorer in die Welt gebracht hat,
in der Zeit seines Existierens, hat nur deswegen ein so großes Ausmaß,
weil er vorinstalliert mitgeliefert wurde.
Dann gab es dieses Kartellverfahren, dann wurde gesagt, ihr nutzt eure marktbeherrschende
Stellung auf dem Betriebssystemmarkt aus,
um eine marktbeherrschende Stellung auf dem Browsermarkt zu erlangen und somit
Konkurrenz auf dem Browsermarkt zu behindern.
Da gab es auch kein Gesetz der USA, wo drin stand, man darf einem US keinen Browser beilegen,
sondern da wurde halt gesagt, hier findet eine Ausnutzung einer marktbeherrschenden
Stellung zur Einschränkung der Konkurrenz statt.
Und ähnlich würde ich sagen, wird das hier bei dieser DMA-Auslegung stattfinden.
Eine abschließende Liste der spezifischen Handlungen,
die zu unterlassen oder zu ergreifen sind, Um eine Monopolstellung zu verhindern
oder nicht bösartig auszunutzen,
ist glaube ich auch nicht zu erstellen.
Insofern wäre ich an der Stelle etwas nachsichtig.
Ja gut, also um Monopol geht es ja hier nicht, sondern es geht um diese Gatekeeper-Funktion.
Genau, also dieses Gatekeeping heißt ja im Prinzip Ausnutzen der Marktbeherrschung
der Stellung zur Einschränkung der Konkurrenz.
Naja, gucken wir mal also das geht jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal ein bisschen hin und her aber dieses,
Pressrelease bezieht sich ja auch nicht nur auf Apple, sondern es gibt ja auch
noch eine zweite Strafandrohung für Meta, hier sind es dann nur 200 Millionen Euro,
da geht es um dieses Pay-or-OK Modell, also es wird sozusagen beklagt dass Meta
jetzt hier nur die Benutzer unseren Facebook-Dienst und Instagram etc.
So wie immer, dann kriegst du alles kostenlos oder du bezahlst eine Gebühr,
dann werden die Daten nicht so abgegriffen.
Ja, und wenn ich es jetzt richtig sehe, ich habe mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau angeschaut,
beklagen Sie hier, dass es keinen dritten Weg gibt, dass es also keine Möglichkeit
gibt, nicht zu bezahlen und keine Daten abzuliefern.
Genau. Also im Prinzip ist ja dieses,
also Pay or Okay ist ja letztendlich auch das, was wir bei dem Besuch jeder
einzelnen Nachrichtenseite in Deutschland haben.
Wir haben Werbung, wir haben Tracking.
Du kannst entweder einwilligen, dass das stattfindet, oder uns Geld geben.
Und dieses Modell als solches, und auch da kann man natürlich die unterschiedlichen,
Motivationen irgendwie feststellen, aber die Vorgabe ist, die Nutzung der Dienste
muss ohne Tracking möglich sein.
Und die Antwort der Unternehmen ist,
eine Interpretation davon zu sagen, ja, so ist es ja möglich,
aber irgendwie muss sich der Bums hier finanzieren.
Eine kostenlose Nutzung unserer Dienste ist ohnehin nicht möglich.
Also entweder die Leute kriegen eine kostenlose, indem sie den ganzen,
allen Anforderungen, die wir hier mit Tracking haben, zustimmen oder eben nicht.
Und damit wird natürlich diese Idee, eine Tracking-freie Nutzung der Kerndienste
muss möglich sein, natürlich ad absurdum geführt.
Gleichermaßen ist klar, dass die Unternehmen jetzt auch nicht unbedingt sagen
werden, naja, nee, hast recht, wir machen hier eine Gratis-Variante oder so.
Besonders ärgerlich, muss ich sagen, finde ich es, dass ich auch,
wenn ich bezahle, keine werbefreie Nutzung bekomme. Ja, also.
Ich habe ja, um hier auch die Recherche für diese Sendung zu machen,
bei einem Großteil der Medien die Paid Accounts und ich kann denen dann da irgendwas
zwischen 10 und 30 Euro im Monat geben und dann werde ich immer noch getrackt
und muss dann mit 3,90 Euro extra zahlen.
Und wir hatten hier auch schon vor längerem darüber gesprochen,
dass diese gesamte Pay-or-OK-Nummer natürlich nur dem Zweck dient,
die Einwilligung zu bekommen fürs Tracking.
Es ist ja kein ernst gemeintes ökonomisches Angebot,
oder eine ökonomische Strategie dieser Unternehmen, sich auf eine trackingfreie
Zeit vorzubereiten und damit dieses Geld zu verdienen.
Und das ist eben dieses Pay or Okay. Ich bin gespannt, wie sich das,
also ich finde das sehr schwierig zu diskutieren, weil irgendwie muss der Kram finanziert werden.
Facebook überhaupt entstehen zu lassen war sowieso ein großer Fehler.
Aber es ist völlig klar, dass es in Wirklichkeit ist, dieses Pay-all-okay ist
einfach nur da, um den Nein-ich-möchte-nicht-getrackt-Button mit einem Preisschild zu versehen.
Und das wiederum ist eine...
Nicht die Umsetzung des Willens der Regulatoren.
Ja, also die Forderung, dass irgendetwas komplett kostenlos sein darf,
die halte ich ja für unangemessen.
Also das kann man jetzt einfach von einem Unternehmen nicht erwarten,
dass sie quasi Dienstleistungen anbietet, die dann auf jeden Fall kostenlos
angeboten werden können müssen.
Aber zu fordern, dass, wenn man dafür bezahlt, dann auch die Möglichkeit hat,
überhaupt nicht gedrängt zu werden, die halte ich wiederum für extrem angemessen.
Ja, ja. Vielleicht dann doch besser zerschlagen, den ganzen Apparat hier.
Das wäre natürlich gut.
Es findet gerade ein Kartellprozess gegen Meta statt, also den Facebook-Konzern.
Und das ist ein sehr interessantes Verfahren aus vielerlei Gründen.
Facebook hatte vor inzwischen vielen Jahren sowohl Instagram als auch WhatsApp gekauft.
Ich glaube, Instagram war eine Milliarde.
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Damals noch ein enorm kleiner Dienst. Das war eher so eine kleine Shopping-Investition.
Aber auch mit der Milliarde sportlich bezahlt, weil das Ding halt kaum Nutzer hatte.
Und ich glaube auch nur irgendwie weniger Angestellte, die sich über diese Milliardenausschüttung
natürlich auch ganz gut freuen konnten.
Und dann WhatsApp wiederum, das war ein zweistelliger Milliardenbetrag,
waren das 11 oder 13 Milliarden?
Auch eine in beiden Fällen,
Und das ist, glaube ich, das Entscheidende. Eine Kaufsumme, die irrsinnig hoch war,
wenn man sie als normales Investment gesehen hätte, mit der Erwartung,
dass sich dieses Investment eines Tages rentiert.
19 Milliarden.
19 Milliarden. Da hatte WhatsApp aber auch schon einige Milliarden Nutzer wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich so eine Milliarde, würde ich denken, wenn die zu dem Zeitpunkt gehabt haben.
Ich weiß, dass ich da damals, glaube ich, bei Netzpolitik.org sogar darüber
berichtet habe, dass das dann pro Nutzer irgendwie ein Funny war.
Also 4 Milliarden in Bar und der Rest dann in Aktien. Und dann nochmal 3 Milliarden
vielleicht später hinterher.
Und 450 Millionen Nutzer.
Okay, also die hatten noch nicht mal eine halbe Milliarde Nutzer und wurden
insgesamt, wurden da also,
grob überschlagen, fast 40 Dollar pro Account bezahlt.
Aber Facebook selber war da zu dem Zeitpunkt auch erst bei 1,2 Milliarden.
Also schon ein Drittel von Facebook.
Also auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich hoher Preis. In beiden Fällen war dieser Preis ziemlich hoch.
Vor allem bei WhatsApp für die Anzahl der Mitarbeiter dort und die Anzahl der...
Elf Leute oder so, ne?
Ja, bestenfalls. Und vor allem auch die Anzahl der Computer,
die sie für irgendwie für den Dienst im Einsatz hatten. Das war auch nicht so viel.
Ja, weil die jetzt alles mit Erlang einfach mal kurz weggemacht hat.
Tja. Klug. Klug.
Ja, ja. Nicht irgendwie lass uns mal hier... Genau.
Naja. Ja. So, jetzt ist also dieser große Konzern Facebook hingegangen und hat
zwei mächtige Konkurrenten Video- und Bildersharing und Instant-Messaging gekauft
zu besonders hohen Preisen.
Und nun, wo sie dann Teil dieses Milliardenkonzerns Meta waren,
war es natürlich auch wiederum sehr schwer, in irgendeiner Weise noch mit Meta
zu konkurrieren, weil sich Meta eben diese andere Nutzerbasis WhatsApp,
diese andere Nutzerbasis Instagram dazu gekauft hat, Funding und so weiter.
Und es ist ja auch richtig, dass es im Bereich der sozialen Netzwerke relativ,
also könnte man Meta eine marktdominierende Position nachsagen.
So, es war aber natürlich so, dass diese Akquisitionen von der FTC genehmigt waren zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und jetzt sagt die FTC, ja gut, aber wir konnten ja damals, ihr habt ja damals
argumentiert, das sind andere Bereiche und wir konnten ja nicht wissen,
wie sich das mit dem Internet entwickelt und dass ihr jetzt auf einmal alles dominiert.
Also gucken wir uns das mal wieder an und kommen vielleicht rückblickend zu dem Ergebnis.
Keine andere Sau hätte 19 Milliarden oder was auch immer für WhatsApp bezahlt.
Also habt ihr hier auch den Preis natürlich, quasi allein durch das,
was ihr dafür bezahlt habt, habt ihr Konkurrenz schon verhindert.
Nämlich, dass dieser Teil des Internets, des Geldes, das im Internet verdient
werden kann, an andere geht.
Und ihr habt ja dann auch, das haben wir vor vielen Jahren diskutiert,
hat Facebook ja dann irgendwann angefangen, die Dinge zu merchen und hat gesagt,
so jetzt führen wir mal Facebook Messenger und WhatsApp zusammen und gucken
wir mal, was es da für Möglichkeiten gibt. Dann gab es da wieder Geschrei.
Und dann ist es so, die FTC ist eine Regierungsorganisation.
Die hat diese Klage 2020 während der ersten Amtszeit von Donald Trump eingereicht.
Dann hat der Joe Biden die Klage weiter verfolgen lassen und,
Dann kam Donald Trump wieder und plötzlich haben wir Videos von Mark Zuckerberg,
der dann sagt, ja und endlich ist hier wieder Meinung.
Dank Donald Trump ist jetzt Meinungsfreiheit auf Facebook wieder und die Fact-Checking
und so weiter, das machen wir demnächst gar nicht mehr. und die Hate-Speech-Kontrolle
verlegen wir nach Texas und so.
Und hier ist noch eine Million für die Inauguration. Und es war schon erkennbar,
dass Mark Zuckerberg erstaunlich, erstaunlich tief im Enddarm von Donald Trump unterwegs war.
Und das könnte natürlich damit zu tun haben, dass er sich sehr anstrengen wollte,
dass dieses etwas ärgerliche Verfahren vielleicht doch noch eingestellt wird.
Ich glaube, die hatten bis zu 450 Milliarden Strafe an die FTC geboten, um das abzuwenden.
Aber die FTC sagt, na, lass mal gucken, ob wir euch nicht zwingen,
euch wieder von WhatsApp und Instagram zu trennen.
Und dann wird natürlich ein potenziell sehr interessanter Effekt eintreten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jemand WhatsApp für den Preis kaufen würde,
den Meta damals bezahlt hat.
Keine Ahnung, also ich würde es nicht haben wollen.
Heute? Naja, also die 16 Milliarden ist es locker wert.
Die Frage ist, wie? Also wie monetarisierst du WhatsApp?
So wie sich die anderen Messenger zum Beispiel in Asien auch monetarisieren.
Du verkaufst halt irgendwie Dienste an Firmen, die darüber Support-Kanäle machen
und du machst halt Bezahlsysteme darüber.
Okay. Ja gut. Also ich behalte meine 19 Milliarden lieber und kaufe... Ja.
Kann ich verstehen.
Gott, ich nehme... Apple-Computer-Fund.
Oder ein Motorrad, kommst du ja jetzt auch langsam in das Alter.
Ja, 19 Milliarden Motorrad.
Diese Verfahren werden wir mal anschauen. Interessanterweise,
während das eben ein Kartellverfahren ist, spielt da natürlich auch noch offenbar
irgendwie so ein Mark Zuckerberg hat es nicht geschafft, Donald Trump ausreichend.
Ausreichend in den Arsch zu kriechen, um dieses Verfahren nochmal irgendwie
abzuwenden. Spielt da halt auch nochmal eine Rolle.
Bin sehr gespannt, wie dieses Verfahren weiterläuft.
Es wäre natürlich auch schon lustig, wenn die FTC jetzt Facebook zerschlägt.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie das, ich glaube nicht, dass das passiert.
Das wird mit Sicherheit nicht passieren. Also zumindest nicht unter Trump,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Zumal ja jetzt ohnehin so ein neuer Protektionismus-Einsatz,
den wir vorhin übrigens gar nicht angesprochen haben, der ja auch schon im Rahmen
der DMA-Verlautbarung der EU jetzt aufkam, dass also die Trump-Regierung jetzt so,
wenn amerikanische Unternehmen woanders bedrängt werden, erpresst werden,
dass sie dagegen irgendwie vorgehen wollen.
Das könnte auch nochmal ein interessanter Battle werden in dem Zusammenhang.
Tja, okay.
So, noch ein bisschen Follow-up hast du aufgeschrieben.
Na, mir ist aufgefallen, bei der LMP 500 hatten wir ja drei spannende Gäste.
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht sicher, ob man das Wort Gast jetzt gendert oder
nicht, aber es waren weibliche weibliche Gäste.
Da gibt es bestimmt ein paar Jungs, die uns das in den Kommentaren ausführlich erklären können.
Da bin ich mir sicher. Tim weiß übrigens Mansplaining, das kommt von Man und Explain.
Wirklich?
Danke.
Wollte ich dir kurz erklären.
Es gibt eine Petition zu dem Kumpum.
Also wir erinnern uns, Anne Brohr-Hilker ist jetzt bei der NGO Finanzwende,
hat es ja ausführlich bei uns erklärt in der Sendung und da gibt es jetzt einen
Appell an die zukünftige Führung des Finanzministeriums.
Ab Januar 2026 dürfen Banken und Unternehmen Dokumente vernichten,
die ihre Verwicklung in illegale Cum-Cum-Geschäfte beweisen würden.
Sobald die Dokumente weg sind, sind also auch die illegal hinterzogenen Steuermilliarden
unwiederbringlich verloren, weil man das nicht mehr nachweisen kann.
Wie praktisch.
Ja, praktisch. Und deswegen ruft uns die Finanzwende dazu auf,
die Petition zu unterzeichnen, dass der oder die nächste Finanzministerin jetzt
handeln muss und die potenziell 28,5 Milliarden Euro an illegal hinterzogenen
Steuergeldern noch in diesem Jahr konsequent zurückzufordern.
Also, da muss jetzt zacksch, da muss was rein.
Und diese Forderung, denke ich, unterstützen wir.
Wir wissen ja, dass wir Steuerhinterziehung nicht gut finden,
erst recht nicht, wenn sie nach
meiner Einschätzung auch eher sogar Steuerdiebstahl oder Steuerbetrug ist.
Soll denn das Finanzministerium an die CDU oder an die SPD gehen?
Hast du das mitbekommen?
Es ist nicht sogar, es war Wirtschaftsminister.
Ich muss das mal ganz kurz googeln.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt schon fest steht.
Ganz klar sind die,
ich gucke mal, Schattenkabinett, März mögliches, es ist aber eher Februar,
das ist Titanic, okay, sorry.
Also, wir können es kurz machen, ich glaube, es ist vollkommen egal,
Die SPD hat sich da jetzt auch nicht besonders hervorgetan.
Herr Scholz war da ja nun auch tief mit drin verwickelt in diese ganze Cum-Ex-Geschichte.
Von daher wundert das ja auch nicht, dass er da auch als Kanzler nicht so richtig
in die Aktion reingegangen ist.
Und die CDU, würde ich sagen, steht jetzt nicht unbedingt im Ruf,
so eine Aufräumer-Mentalität zu haben, wenn es um den Markt und die Wirtschaft geht.
Trotzdem, Petition ist da. Wir unterstützen die Petition und rufen zu ihrer Zeichnung auf.
Link findet ihr in den Shownotes und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann war ja außerdem Elenos bei uns zu Gast und hat unter anderem dem Quartiersmanagement
Grunewald berichtet und das wird sich natürlich auch dieses Jahr wieder am 1.
Mai versammeln in Grunewald und ich muss sagen, der diesjährige Aufruf ist wunderschön.
Der Planet Erde wird nämlich eine endmilliardäre... Meine Güte.
Der Planet Erde wird eine endmilli...
Entmilliardarisierte Zone sein.
Entmilliardarisierte Zone, ja. Und da werden also Milley, Musk und Merz werden
zum Mars geschossen, ja.
Und dafür gibt es dann eben die Cape Grunewal, was ich auch sehr schön finde.
Cape Grunewal, wo das Spaceship starten wird.
Das ist alles sehr schön.
Die Milliardäre werden zum Mars geschossen, Das sind die Grunewald Space Agency,
das ist also die GESA, eröffnet am 1. Mai in Grunewald.
Das ist das International Space Shuttle My Ass und die fliegen dann zum Mars.
Dann gibt es die ganzen Space Workerinnen, die da hinkommen werden und das ist
schon alles, es ist wirklich wieder sehr schön und sehr, sehr spaßig,
was da stattfinden wird.
Eine sichere An- und Abreise des Bodenpersonals wird gewährleistet durch unterschiedliche Radtouren.
Auch das sehr schön, den Zubringer von Respect Cyclists über den Kudamm.
Mehrere Finger, Falkplatz, Gesundbrunnen, Hermannplatz, 11 Uhr Brandenburger
Tor, vor allem dann nach Grunewald.
Das ist sehr schön, fährt man einmal durch die Stadt mit dem Rad.
Und dann gibt es den Wegbringer der Bürgerinitiative A100 über die Autobahn.
Das geht 16 Uhr am Johannaplatz los, also ehemals Johannaplatz,
das ist jetzt der Spaceport Cape Grunewald, aber da dann über die A100 zurück.
Das kann ich übrigens auch sehr empfehlen, es gibt wenig Dinge,
die schöner sind, als mit dem Rad über die Berliner Stadtautobahn zu fahren.
Das ist richtig geil. Das ist richtig geil.
Werde ich mir unter keinen Umständen entgehen lassen und könnte da auch sehr,
sehr zu raten, einen angenehmen...
1. Mai bei der Wiederbelebung des deutschen Space-Programms zu verbringen.
Letztlich tut sich da mal was.
Und dann machen die natürlich auch immer Musikvideos. Ich denke mal,
vielleicht spielen wir das als Bonus-Track ein.
Aber ihr solltet unbedingt dieses Video schauen,
weil das schon sehr ohrwurmlastig und sehr lustig ist.
Berliner Hackerinnen und Hacker werden oder auch, weiß nicht, Leute, die nicht aus,
Berlin kommen, werden da auch den Drehort sicherlich wiedererkennen,
an dem dieses schöne Video gedreht wurde.
Alright. Jetzt noch Werbung?
Ach, ich weiß nicht, ist das Werbung? Ich rufe ja hier an dieser Stelle öfter mal dazu auf, dass ich,
oder weise darauf hin, Dass ich eventuell mich freuen würde über Bewerbungen
von Leuten mit ein bisschen Erfahrung im IT-Security-Consulting,
Red-Teaming, Pentesting, auch
ganz klassische strategische Consulting-Sachen. Würde ich mich freuen.
Ein Link zu meinem Kontaktformular ist in den Shownotes, falls ihr da gerade
euch beruflich neu orientieren wollt.
Zufällig.
Zufällig. Könnt ihr euch ja mal melden.
Alright, das war's. Mehr haben wir nicht für euch diese Woche.
Und haben wir weiterhin keinen regelmäßigen Veröffentlichungszeitplan.
Ja, werden wir sehen.
Wir richten uns nach der Nachrichtenlage. Solange,
alles bergab geht, gibt's ja nix Neues.
Aber immer was zu lachen.
Ja.
Leute, das war's. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.